veteran right hander will sink it he'll
throw you a good change up for seamer
and a curve ball he is on 14 of his 19
decisions and has a 4.04 era he's steady
and those 14 wins especially for a team
that's kind of falling apart that leads
all of baseball right now connor swings
and hits it fair inside the third base
bag down the line grabbing it up against
the ivy is the left fielder hap it'll be
a lead off double for connor joe keeps
swinging a good bat the talented right
fielder of the rockies charlie blackman
hitting at 276 on the year with nine
homers and 59 rbis this ball lined to
right center field connor joe around
third he'll score and charlie blackman
gives the rockies a one-nothing lead on
the road this is just the second time in
sam hilyard's career that he's come up
with the bases loaded the 1-1 is hit off
the end of the bat and into left center
field for a base hit it will score a
pair
and hillyard is out at second base
trying to make it a double but sam
hilliard adds to the advantage three
nothing here in the first who has not
won yet on the road this year this will
be his ninth road start he's oh and five
with a 580. yeah and he's also looking
for his first win since june second he's
had nine starts since then hasn't been
bad and a slider in an unhittable spot
so a very nice beginning as rafael
ortega swings and misses
oh two pitch swinging and a miss on a
breaking ball
back to back strikeouts for senzatella
round ball through in the right center
field this could be extra bases half
around first he's racing the second and
he'll stop there so a two out double for
ian half
patrick wisdom swings at the first pitch
rolls it to third mcmahon across the
diamond they get him the double does no
damage the double for connor was his
eighth double he has
15 extra base hits and this is 53rd game
as a rocky
breaking ball hit towards left field and
it's going to drop in front of ian happ
and connor joe is two for two fun to
watch him hit he can do a lot of things
and we've talked about his play
discipline jack the ability to draw some
walks the ability to hang with counts
really timed that curveball nicely and
stayed back and got enough of it one-o
to rogers he swings and hits one in the
air to right giving chase his hermacillo
right near the foul line makes the catch
rockies get a hit leave a man we move
into the bottom of the second inning the
rockies with a three to nothing
advantage payoff pitch from senzatella
curveball strike three call he just
froze david body who
flipped the bat away and tried to say no
that was a ball but yeah it was in there
david knew it too but when you're fooled
like that you try and do that and hope
sensatella fires swaying and a miss got
him with a hard breaking slider
antonio senzatella gets his fourth
strikeout so here's schwendell struck
out against senzatella first pitch
bounces it up the middle rogers the
shortstop has it and sidearms to throw
over to first base
and it's a ground ball out on the first
pitch at the bottom of the fourth for
antonio senzatella one two pitch swing
and a miss got him on the slider down
and away and antonio senzatella collects
strikeout number six on a beautiful
breaking ball three-nothing rockies in
the fourth pitch to bodhi is hit in the
air center field moving back hillyard at
the ivy he reaches up and makes the
catch
long fly ball but sam hilliard brings it
in and antonio senzatella says no
problem to that infield single antonio
senzatella has been cruising one two
swing and a drive to centerfield but
coming in on it is hilliard to make the
catch two outs in the air here in the
fifth inning for the cubs a pitch to
hendricks he swings away and grounds one
into right field for a base hit so the
cubs have something cooking here with
two away in the bottom of the fifth
inning then at first and second and
rafael ortega do up
shallow left and what a catch by mcmahon
what a grab by mcmahon and you can add
another point to his drs defensive run
save
ryan mcmahon with great
athleticism
takes a blue base hit
and a rally killer to end the fifth
righty whines and
cj delivers fair into the right field
corner
it'll be a leadoff double for cj crone a
three three-hit night for c.j
diaz grounds once softly to third
charging wisdom slings it to first two
away and crone has to stay at second
that'll bring up sam hilliard hendricks
leans in gets the sign from torino sets
kicks and fires swung on and missed
strike three and krone is left at third
base the bases are loaded for david body
body cracks one on the ground to short
rogers to second for one on the first
double play but the cubs score their
first run of the game as schwindel comes
home advancing the third base is half
but two down here in the sixth
hermesio swings and pops it up
first baseman cj crone drifting with the
win but stays with it and that ends the
inning base is loaded nobody out and the
cubs only get one the rockies have
runners at the corners with nobody out
joe swings and drives it towards right
backing up and making the play as here
macio tagging and scoring is hampson and
down to second base is ruiz
sacrifice fly for connor joe and the
rockies lead four to one there's a new
pitcher on the mound for colorado
veteran right-hander yolice shasin
got some good defensive help here's a
ball that's
slashed to third base good pick by ryan
mcmahon who throws over to first for the
out boy ryan mcmahon with another quick
reaction to make the play
looking to make it a clean inning and
this pitch is hit in the air to left
field connor joe in three steps and he
makes the catch and jolish shaseen
retires the side in order bases are
loaded for the cubs here in the bottom
of the eighth inning
he swings and lines one set into center
field one run is in and that's all for
now the bases remain loaded the rbi
single by patrick wisdom moves the cubs
to within two
bodhi rips one to short rogers to second
for one on the first
double play but coming in to score is
schwendel
and the cubs are within one it's
colorado four the cubs three from a sale
swing strikes one to deep left field
this will one hop off the wall tie ball
game hat scores as hermes seal cruises
in the second base win an rbi double 4-4
here in the eighth at wrigley hayward
the winning run at first and it'll bring
up rafael ortega hayward goes the pitch
deep to right field way back this could
go
gone
rafael ortega a walk-off two-run home
run and the cubs and the streak